i'm gonna roll with that it's gonna be
groundbreaking lori lachlan is
officially settling in
back home after completing a nearly
two-month prison sentence
for her role in the 2019 college
admission scandal
and now a source is opening up to e.t
about her emotional homecoming with her
daughters
and her plan to get back to work we've
had our moments
but but overall i'm happy a source tells
e.t
that the 56-year-old actress who was
released from the federal correctional
institution in dublin california on
december 28th
has started talking about getting her
life back we're just
a nice normal family our source says
lori would love to start working again
and she's already had her team put out
feelers but she's scared people
might not want to work with her go for
the gold right you gotta do it
as for that whole serving time thing the
source says prison was
unlike anything lori has ever
experienced in her life
and heading home was like a dream come
true we did talk about things like that
and you know the importance of
not listening to what the press has to
say or what other people have to say
being the best that you can be taking
care of yourself just
a little refresher the fuller house star
began her prison sentence on october
30th
surrendering herself to authorities a
few weeks early
after pleading guilty in may to one
count of conspiracy to commit wire and
mail fraud
and honest services wire and mail fraud
she has also been ordered to pay
a 150 000 fine and complete
100 hours of community service as for
lori's hubby
massimo gianouli with whom she shares 21
year old olivia jade and 22 year old
bella
he began his five-month prison sentence
for his involvement in the scandal
back in november and while our source
says lori is counting down the days
until massimo is home
their girls put together a special
homecoming for their mom
with flowers decorations and her
favorite foods
quote she was emotionally overwhelmed by
how much she missed them
and still has to remind herself that if
anything good came out of
all this it's their closeness and
renewed faith in their tight-knit family
and the source says that laurie's time
in prison really gave her some time to
think
while she kept her girls quiet for so
long regarding details of this
experience
she realizes that talking about this is
a healthy part of the process to get
past it all
she was really proud of olivia for
speaking out on red table talk
and taking the steps she needed to move
forward from this scandal
i think every single person in my family
can be like that was messed up
that was a big mistake but i think
what's so important to me is like
to learn from the mistake not to now be
shamed and punished and never given a
second chance because i'm
21 i feel like i deserve a second chance
to redeem myself to show i've grown
yeah and olivia it appears she's ready
to get back to work too
she recently teased a return to youtube
posting
this clip to tiktok alongside the
caption like this if i should bring back
my vlogs
hi everybody it's olivia jade welcome
back to my youtube channel and when one
fan
commented damn near begging her to get
back in the spotlight and
back on youtube this was her response
thank you so much for the sweet comment
i just want to say first of all comments
like this actually make my day
and i just i'm really grateful and also
okay i will i guess i will come back to
[Music]
youtube